it's done he says what do you mean it's
done i said it means no more checks and
i said to him the dead bird under the
nest never learns how to fly
and he said what the [ __ ] does that mean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr wonder mr wonderful is that a is that
an uh richard millie on your wrist no
this is a hot new company you know i'm
huge in watches here we go and
you know listen i don't own any equity
in them they're just i just appreciate
the art of making great pieces of entity
and they're out of australia and i
always tell these young watchmakers
listen i'm very supportive uh but make
me a single one-of-a-kind piece that i
can feature on shark tank and this is
going to be this season's this is a
crazy watch i mean
and you're not involved in the company
no sometimes i just want to help the
artist
you know it's just
i've made lots of money and you know i
want to give back a little bit here but
people know me as a watch guy and
you know they really look at what i wear
particularly on shark tank all around
the world i got the red band and so
these days i got a lot of watches
already and i say to all these makers
look i don't need another watch i try
and wear four a day and i still can't
get through
you know
a tenth of the collection what's your
skin care routine look like you have
incredible
skin dude hey mr wonderful here with the
world opening back up every guy needs to
invest in how they're presenting
themselves that's why i'm excited to
have tiege hanley as a sponsor of
today's video you've heard me talk about
them before and i'm going to keep
talking about them because they use
their products look i'll admit skin care
wasn't something i always focused on but
since i started using their system i've
seen improvements in the way my skin
looks and feels and it kind of helps me
present myself i want to look good i
recommend you start with their level one
system here it is right here which comes
with all the basics
a daily face wash an exfoliating scrub
an am moisturizer with spf 20 is a big
thing for me that's what keeps the dome
safe
and a pm moisturizer keeps the skin
moist one thing i appreciate about teeth
handling is how they make it easy they
give you an instruction card that tells
you when to use each product how much to
use and what order you don't have to
take my word for it because they have
over 5 000 5 star review from satisfied
customers all around the world also
tiege hanley members get tons of
benefits including at least 20 off the
retail price
free us shipping access to exclusive
monthly deals try the level one system
which comes with all the basics a daily
face wash an exfoliating scrub an am
moisturizer with spf 20 and a pm
moisturizer for while you sleep all for
30 bucks which is super affordable and
they ship it right to you and because
tiege hanley is sponsoring today's video
they're offering my viewers a great deal
just click the link in the description
and not only will you get teach handling
for the best possible price i love that
but they'll also give you a free gift
with your first box
click that link and get started today i
don't endorse products i don't use but
this am spf 20 keeps the dome of desire
looking just
[Music]
wonderful
check out teach hanley
it's all about skin and how you feel and
how you look you do so much
you do so much i was with mark roberts
this morning yeah our mutual friend yeah
he's like a step dad to me my miami step
dad
tell me what he owns
tell the people mark roberts owns 11 and
a plethora of other things real estate
and he's he's a business common man um
and i i said yo what what do i ask kevin
you know and so uh he told me to ask you
about your routine
yeah well mark and i get up at the same
time 5 a.m 5 a.m and i work out for now
right away
either i take my bike out on you know on
the causeway or i take a cruise down the
beach or something or i hit the machines
but
i'm reading stuff uh from five to six
and then maybe i do a cnbc hit or
something tomorrow i'm going to do good
morning america but i want to be i want
to be wired by the time i'm on
television i want to be worked out and i
want to feel you know healthy and he's
the same way and that's we sort of got
to know each other around that routine
and i just think it's a good way to live
because you get that time by yourself to
do your stuff
nobody bugs you nobody's up at five
o'clock
i am and you know and i do a lot of work
in the middle east now and i'm doing
stuff in dubai and abu dhabi and all and
all these international investments and
people who work 24 7 anyways so you can
get a lot done yeah yeah what are you
reading when you read i read research uh
that's sent out to me because my my
biggest business is financial services
and you know we make indexes for
sovereign wealth and pension plans so i
got to know what's going on in the
financial markets but you know at this
conference that we're all at here in
miami uh crypto bitcoin 2022 for the
first time on the first day i looked out
in the audience it was all the giant
institutional investors
they've never come to this conference
never and i started asking guys what are
you doing here and they're saying we
sense the world's changing we see the
policy coming we see these senators
showing up here we know they're going to
make this thing investable it's going to
be huge you even gave your business
advice to mark
of course i tell them what to do every
day it doesn't doesn't always listen but
he's doing are you the reason he's rich
no but we're in a couple of deals
together we really are we invest
together in some things um
we've got a company called immutable
holdings that owns nft.com they just
launched they're huge i'm an advisor did
you know that yeah i know that i
actually talked to jordan i mentioned we
were going to get together and i like
what he's doing in creating that whole
new vision of nft.com and when i a lot
of artists approach me and say listen
where do i put my infrastructure where's
my building blocks i say talk to him
like you know jordan free is is doing
the right thing and i know you're
involved as well but i've also got mark
in that deal and we've gotten that to
one together uh we did something with
wonderfuy which is a canadian crypto we
own the entire canadian crypto exchange
license and we're centralized and
decentralized uh we're taking that into
the middle east with the uae and brazil
uh we're trying to get what i'm trying
to do on crypto is is get the
the government's licenses so we're not
rogue cowboy guys so we can work with
the government and and build regulated
exchanges because that's what i think is
going to happen yeah yeah and the
government loves that yeah sure so uae
brazil switzerland these guys are
advanced england the same way so i think
wonderful will eventually become a giant
holding company for all these these are
licensed exchanges around the world yep
how many different entities verticals
industries are you in because you you
like everything that we mentioned you
have a company in you know what i'm
saying or you have an advisor on a board
like like you know what i'm saying like
do you own any cheeseburger uh
or casual dining uh i actually own a
bunch of
food companies but i tell you where i'm
going with it i don't there's a lot of
you know shark tank's always two years
ahead of the market the deals we see are
coming right
i saw this one it just aired called
magic dates so i'm into healthier eating
now and i don't eat a lot of shitty food
but she found a way um to actually take
date paste and make a very very healthy
snack that tastes sweet that doesn't
spike your glucose her sales are going
through the roof because mothers want to
give their kids healthy stuff so
i found some strategic investors to join
me in the deal we're going to blow the
company up because
one of the great things about being a
shark everybody returns your calls like
i could call the head of walmart and get
a call back and say look let's help this
woman she's a female ceo let's help moms
buy healthy snacks let's blow this thing
up together you know it's just good
business yeah and so i'm into healthier
foods now
i'm trying to get out of the soft thing
i mentioned that earlier but i got a lot
of deals i mean
it's i feel that celebrity you should
use it to help people
you know that's when i and you're doing
the same thing i'm trying to say look
i'm an entrepreneur you're an
entrepreneur you can't get your call
returned i can
i'll buy a piece your company will go
into the journey together and i can do
things for you you can't do yourself
that's being i think a good investor
i found mike on the street
he was literally you should put him
right back there yeah i still
i still am
i'm still there
no that's not true um but you're
absolutely right putting people on is is
amazing and i can't imagine how good you
feel putting all that literally changing
lives yeah it's great and and look you
don't you you can still do business you
can still be an investor but you've got
to find things you're i like to spend my
day doing [ __ ] i like yeah so the the
you know i i have a great woman here in
nancy chung she allocates the time we do
so much work and then we say what are
these things that i don't want to do
because i don't have to do anything yeah
that's the whole idea of being
entrepreneurs not about the greed of
money it's about the pursuit of personal
freedom i do whatever i like but i like
to do stuff that's you know interesting
and so i surround myself with
interesting people i got a great crew we
do interesting stuff we go all over the
world and we're investors and you know
entrepreneurship is not the pursuit of
greed it doesn't work people smell
[ __ ] a mile away you got to be
transparent what happens to a person who
has too big of a heart because i feel
like when i try to hire friends or when
i try to if i see an employee like keep
failing but i know he's a good person i
know he's he has the capability like i
feel like my biggest fault and the
reason why i'm not where i need to be is
because my heart keeps
my path up like crazy you have to make
that differentiation you've got to put
metrics in place the worst thing you can
do is hire your brother sister or uncle
cousin who works for you by the way your
assistant who is that my sister yeah but
by the way crushes it she's the only
employee that i trust the hardest thing
to do is get the whacking stick out when
you know you have to do it if you're
putting a team together if you're
building a business you've got to have a
discipline of setting goals achieving
them and if they can't reach them
it's behind the barn and you know what
you have to do you got to you gotta move
on you gotta move on
you gotta keep your crew tight you have
to make sure that everybody understands
what they're doing and particularly when
you're building a business you gotta
allocate as you're building it and gets
bigger and you've gotta find good people
i've made most of my money in
investments investing in women
if you look at all these shark tank
deals over 14 years 75 returns came from
companies run by women they're better at
mitigating risk so i'm already biased at
backing women you see my returns because
they're you know they're all added you
want something done give it to a busy
mother it's true they know how to use
their time and so i'm a big advocate for
that i'll invest in any idea that i
think has merit but i invest more with
women now because i've made so much
dough with them world of women dude hey
listen it's a i'd give money to a goat
if i could get a return
like i'm into it for the returns i'm
making but women are very good at this
i'm super curious about this yeah all
right quick anecdote little story
followed by a question sure i took a
class in high school called design squad
i was a straight a student design squad
design squad all i got were a's we'd
we'd be uh tasked with these little um
missions on on you know get a ball from
a to z and make it uh set off a
mousetrap that was the particular one we
were doing this time and yeah just
launch a rocket whatever so are you an
artist is that what you're trying to say
yeah okay so listen if that's a true
story it's not [ __ ] that's
interesting i wanted to be an engineer
i wanted i want to make stuff and we
only had certain materials you know that
was that was the thing and so i'm two
weeks into this project uh it's due the
next day and i'm realizing i can't set
off this mouse trap and i'm looking
around and every other group could and i
couldn't set off the mousetrap and i got
i failed the project and i ended up
because i failed that project getting an
f in that class
and i
throughout the whole process kept trying
to make my thing work and kept trying to
make my thing work and it didn't and i
didn't have the guts
to say [ __ ] i need to start over it's
going to be better for me if i literally
start fresh and i didn't and i screwed
myself and i gotta be in that class
until my parents came in and talked to
the teacher and they had give me extra
credit and then i got an a
so thank you mr purdy for making that
happen so that's pretty amazing you've
got your parents to negotiate a deal did
they get a percentage royalty on that
they did pretty good i bought my mama
house yeah uh that's a lot that's the
right thing to do i bought your dad a
truck bought my dad a truck which he
sold
but i just love you greg but um it was a
actually amazing lesson for me because i
learned like sometimes you need to start
over if you're failing don't be afraid
to start fresh so when
should entrepreneurs if at all pivot wow
that's a great question i have a very
simple rule to this and i tell them all
when i invest in them if you're not
making money
after 36 months three years
you got to take it behind the barn and
shoot it because it's just a hobby it's
not a business and everybody says oh no
no no no no
people get so you know
stuck on a bad idea they just keep
thinking if i keep working on it it's
going to fix it so it doesn't fix itself
it was put on your journey to teach you
what not to do that's the whole idea if
you don't realize the lesson learned
you're
i mean you're going to spend all your
time on some really bad idea and waste
it you've got to pivot and i i tell all
my entrepreneurs this one didn't work
i'll come i'll come visit you with a
good bottle of wine and we'll just drink
it and then we'll take this idea behind
the barn and shoot you spend a lot of
time behind that barn yeah i have you
know not every idea works but the most
important thing is say look it's not
working shoot it like and let's move on
oh i can't do that yes you can i'll do
it for you like it's a rehabilitation
home for all you gotta shoot it you have
to shoot it and then you move on to your
next idea and then you only need one to
work you only need one
you get a winner you go through the roof
yeah
all right mikey
sorry for interrupting uh no i was just
i was gonna go back to some per some
superlatives what is the most successful
business you've invested on uh in as a
result of shark tank
so the number one exit was a deal called
plated okay
two guys from new york city started meal
kits remember that whole thing
where you just a meal comes to your door
every day and then you cook it yeah that
whole idea blue apron was the big guy at
the time got it so
what happened was
the grocer started to see this trend
occurring
and
they saw that whole foods was bought by
amazon and they went oh no so albertson
approached us
at plated and said we'd like to buy you
they bought it for 340 million bucks
that was a shark tank deal it was only
36 months old and it had grown
dramatically and so that was the biggest
exit in shark tank history and that paid
for a lot of my mistakes on shark tank
yeah but there are deals now on shark
tank and there's one being negotiated
right now can't announce it yet
it's actually one run by a woman that's
going to be the largest individual
winner
because because i own a small fraction
of the business and she owns the rest of
it
it's an extraordinary outcome and
she built something incredible and of
course we're going to track it on shark
tank shark tank knows about it but the
deal hasn't been announced yet we're
getting 100 million dollar deals all the
time now in shark tank wow because the
show does one thing the real secret of
shark tank is to understand that it
reduces customer acquisition costs for
its companies
100 million eyeballs see every episode
in syndication so people see products
and they order it online and the company
paid nothing to get the customer you
want to get on shark tank and more you
want to get a deal with a shark so that
you can actually be updated every year
on the updates and that's seen in 42
countries around the world so we change
lives on shark tank every day now who
knew this is going to get this big i
mean this no
you didn't know that we had no idea i
remember season three i said well you
know we got a dog and a cat watching
this show that's it
season four things exploded because we
went into this recessionary period and
started coming out of it and everybody
wanted to be an entrepreneur the reason
we had you here today is yes
we're looking to get a strategic
investor involved uh from the outside
for a small portion of uh of equity in
prime
i don't have any equity i haven't
do you want to try something well tell
me what's in it is it too much sugar or
not well i'm glad you asked kevin yeah
yeah two grams of sugar yeah 10 coconut
water 25 calories it's a hydration 25
calorie that's it
does it taste like shin
you tell me all right give me the flavor
you want me to try it which are you like
sweet guys great tropical punch it's
universal
tropical that's right yeah there you go
okay i love that flavor i'm just gonna
let you know about the ball's gonna rock
this is a really competitive market
right
uh yeah yeah very competitive but we're
you know we're competitive people yeah i
get it and so you're putting your brand
on this
uh yeah yeah it is yeah me and my
business partner ksi
that's not [ __ ]
this tastes good thank you um it's doing
very well i'll tell you the the the
sales yeah let's hear it um
two months in we sold 10 million bottles
10 million bottles how many dollars
how are you getting distribution
yeah one more target kroger cvs vitamin
sharp gnc they approach they built this
business up then approached you to be a
brand ambassador no no started it from
the ground really yeah we worked on it
for you know eight months behind the
scenes it's pretty good because in this
category getting distribution is
everything it is everything that's why
it works we our
manufacturer and our partners so you
don't lend your brand to this or people
just know your prime like how does this
work no no no um
yeah well i'm i'm i'm a co-founder with
uh uh but
if i go online and look at the
advertising this is you are you all over
yes yes
so that's that's you know that makes
sense to me if you have equity in it and
you're promoting it and it's an
entrepreneurial vision which is and
you've achieved that in sales
the the the thing you got to do with
these kinds of
beverage models you got to get yourself
to 50 million in sales
because at 50 million you're starting to
encroach on share of the big boys and
what happens then is they want to buy
you
yeah but it doesn't work till it's 50.
on the way to 50 they're going to do
everything in their power to crush you
and get you off the shelf yeah and so
that's what you're going to be fighting
it's such a competitive space because
the shelf is completely loaded with
competitors and you know who they are
and they don't like
dirty little startups like you yeah but
you have a competitive advantage because
of your brand but you've got to run till
you're at 50. once you're at 50 it's
very defensible so you got to get more
distribution yeah we have some we have
some amazing things planned i mean
honestly we just scratched the surface
in terms of what we're capable of doing
yeah my partner is the biggest uh
influencer celebrity in the united
kingdom we still haven't launched there
those numbers aren't so you're going
internationally
okay i mean you know i probably focus
more on domestic because if you've got
10 it's proof of concept
it's hard to get a million in this
category people struggle like crazy but
if you can actually break through and i
have to say the product doesn't it
tastes good so you're going to get
repeat you know repeat purchase well
what we're seeing is the every single
week there's the sales go up yeah by
drastic percentage and is it is that a
health claim you're making or is it a
boost or what what really is
i mean it is a hydration right it's it's
a very healthy low calorie low sugar
hydration beverage right now you're on
target with the 25 calories people are
freaking out when they're drinking 160
calories per bottle of gatorade 160
calories yeah i mean i know 24 grams of
sort of and that's when you're trying to
count calories that's a lot of people
are when they're working out but
particularly in training programs
you don't want it this is perfect 25
calories so that was the idea i mean
when i see 25 calories i immediately
think oh it's going to taste like [ __ ]
it's going to have that you know fake
sugary fake long aftertaste yeah this
does not have that and i think you're
achieving it with just a small amount of
sugar
that's it so congrats on this but man if
you got 10 you got to get to 50 and
you've got about
i'd say 18 months to get to 50 million
bottles no dollars they're going to do
that
in the next few months i have one
question that it is personal as well uh
i've met my biggest fear is god willing
being very successful and then losing my
kids uh soul in the process because how
am i supposed to like raise
no no for real because i i've never met
and no rarely like one out of ten
really wealthy people do i see their
kids come out to be a great question how
do you raise your kids i see in a humble
life so that's entitlement that's the
that's the uh
so let me tell you a story on that one
that saved my ass and you know i've
applied to my own family when i was
graduating college my mother came to the
graduation she said i've got great news
i'm coming to the graduation
but um i also have some other news
no more checks and i said what do you
mean because she'd been paying for
college and my rent and everything and
she said the dead bird under the nest
never learns how to fly
i said what the hell does that mean she
said no more checks i'm not writing any
more checks you're gonna have to figure
this out on your own you know we've i
paid for your education from i paid for
you from birth the last day of college
we're done
and i thought [ __ ] i mean because i
really had no job or anything and i had
a tough couple of years i mean i
couldn't even pay the rent but it worked
out and i got motivated and you know
obviously i'm pretty happy about the
outcome so when i had my first big
liquidity event when the learning
company got sold i got sold for about
4.2 billion and there was 10 of us that
were founders so
we woke up the next morning and said
[ __ ] we're rich like we didn't even
think about it we came back to work and
kept going but when i went over that was
in in cambridge and i went over to
boston and saw the lawyers and said look
i want to set up a trust
that basically provides for my kids
because they were like four and six at
the time
and
it pays for everything for them
um
until they finish college and then they
get nothing and he said what the hell's
that i said well it's it's
it's a way that i can provide for them
to set them up in life but not entitle
them
i was taking a cue from my mother's
strategy the same idea
and i went home that day and i told my
wife i was going to do this and i sat
down with my two kids and i said here's
how this trust works and everything's
good until even if i get run out by a
truck you're good to finish college and
they went yeah that's great that you
know didn't give a [ __ ] about it they
were four and six so
i can't believe you sat you're four and
a half six year old i had to disclose
what i'd done years later years later
we're still in boston and my son is
doing really poorly in high school he is
sucking and just not applying himself
and
you know his his marks are terrible and
the way to look at high school is it's
just like a test to get into college you
got to you got to pass a few things
and i
so one day he says to me um
i'll never forget this conversation
lynn and i were going out to a movie
that night and he says hey dad one of my
friends was telling me about his trust
fund
and um
what does my trust fund look like and i
said
well i don't know about your friend's
fun but here's how yours works if mom
and i get run over by a truck you're
good until you finish high school
because it doesn't look like you're
going to college he said what do you
mean i said well the trust only pays
till you finish college then it's
it's done he says what do you mean it's
done i said it means no more checks and
i said to him the dead bird under the
nest never learns how to fly
and he said what the [ __ ] does that mean
i said what it means is you should start
thinking about taking advantage of this
now
because you're not
and you're you're not i don't know
what's going to happen to you you're not
even going to finish high school here
and i think at that moment
that the lesson of life you know given
to by my mother must he saw the abyss he
saw the darkness he saw the situation he
was in and went [ __ ] this is bad and so
he he knuckled down and he started
getting into uh in what he was into and
and he eventually became an electrical
engineer and he he was at the top of his
class all through
you know college and right into
engineering and in all these electrical
engineering uh cohorts
they all build a combustion f1 race car
and an electric one
and they embrace them all around the
world against each other because that's
how they're learning if they're
interested in electrical engineering
you're building an f1 formula car and
every year
mit would win
and because they always built the best
car well in trevor's case he became the
captain of the team and he worked on the
software that released the energy out of
the battery in a different way and he
beat mit and so the tesla guys came over
and said who are you guys and he went to
college in mcgill he said we're the
mcgill team and he said you're all hired
at tesla all of you the whole team wow
that's where he works that's where he
lives in san francisco wow
so
that's the lesson of the dead bird right
there yeah yeah applicable advice too
i'm going to do that yeah yeah because
you can take care of them with health
issues but if you guarantee them a free
ride and they never have to take any
risk they won't yeah and you'll destroy
their lives it's the worst curse you
could do everybody knows people that
have really screwed up rich kids it's
and they made that mistake they just
made it too easy for them it's not going
to happen in my family and my trust goes
you know in multi-generations when he
has kids even if they're not married it
takes care of them to write the end of
college if you like that video wait did
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe